The example we just talked about was calculating the
total sales per store. And there are lots of
other things we can do with MapReduce that actually
quite similar to that, for example, log processing. Say
we had a set of logs from a web server which looked like this. You may want to
know how many times each page has been hit.
Well really, it's similar to calculating the sales per store.
Your mapper will read a line of the log at a time. And it will extract
the name of the page. Such as, index.php. It's intermedia data. We'll have
the name of the page as the key. The intermediate data we use index.php
as the key and 1 as the value. This is saying that that page was
accessed one time. Then we'll continue into the other
lines of the file just like that. When all the
mappers are done the reducers will get the keys,
which are just all the pages on our website, and
a list of values which will be a list
of ones, meaning how many times that page was accessed.
The reducers can add up the ones to know how
many total hits that page had on our web site.
Simple, but far more efficient, than writing
a standalone program to go through all
the logs start to finish. Especially, if
we could have hundreds of gigabytes or more.